hey friend why don't you join us why
don't you come back thank you no okay
okay goodbye
I had a very interesting time starring
on a reality show at only the age of 800
but um I don't think I would ever do one
ever again just because they're a little
stressful and I rather do I think a
transition from dance into acting is
different and the same in so many ways
because when you dance you have to act
and you have to show emotion so I think
it really helped me really into acting
it's pretty obvious I have the biggest
crush on Zac Efron I've had it since I
was five years old I will always love
him till the day I die I wish I could
marry him but he's slightly too old for
me
I would say zendaya is a really big
inspiration for me in the fashion world
just because she has so many amazing
looks and it's different every time
sometimes she decides to go more on the
tomboy route or sometimes she decides to
make it super girly and glamorous so
she's definitely a very big inspiration
to me
I had no clue that chandelier would blow
up let alone have over a billion views
and it was probably the best experience
and day of my life when that video
released just because ever since then
it's just been a whirlwind for me to
make sure I love everything that I'm
doing and to always remember that I am
still a child and to never take anything
too far so that I'm not overworked
[Music]
she plays really old music and she'll
dress up and show impersonate all of my
dances that I did when I used to compete
she was the biggest fan of Dance Moms
and she knows more of it than I do
so it's really really funny
[Music]
less is more when you're wearing too
much makeup I feel like you can look
cakey
[Music]
oh it's okay you can't even hear it I
don't know exactly what I'll be doing in
20 years I think I would love to
continue acting and dancing
maybe choreograph some things do a lot
more music videos to see and continue to
feature and a bunch of films
[Music]
I'll show the beautiful